tras un año de trabajo un grupo de
expertos de la ONU presentará este
viernes ante el consejo de los Derechos
Humanos el primer informe de la delicada
situación que se vive en Nicaragua de
acuerdo con lo revelado hoy en Ginebra
por estos expertos en el país
centroamericanos y han cometido y se
siguen cometiendo toda clase de abusos
crímenes de lesa humanidad bajo las
instrucciones del presidente Daniel
Ortega y de su esposa y vicepresidenta
Rosario Murillo el informe señala que de
manera coordinada la policía junto con
grupos paramilitares llevaron a cabo
ejecuciones extrajudiciales en el marco
de las protestas del año 2018 que
dejaron más de 350 nicaragüenses muertos
también quedó plasmado que para callar
cualquier voz disidente cualquier voz
opositora fueron encarcelados
arbitrariamente decenas de personas y
dentro de las cárceles los agentes
penitenciarios los torturaron físicas
psicológicamente como también los
violaron sexualmente otros de los
crímenes consignados más recientemente
son el de la privación arbitraria de la
nacionalidad y del derecho a permanecer
en el propio país y es que recordemos
que el pasado 9 de febrero Ortega
desterró A 222 presos políticos hacia
Washington y junto con ellos otros 94
perdieron completamente la nacionalidad
quedando como a patrias de manera que el
informe pide liberar inmediatamente a
quienes todavía se encuentran en prisión
de manera injusta y le pide a la
comunidad internacional que emprenda
acciones legales lo más pronto en contra
de todos los individuos responsables de
estos crímenes dentro del gobierno de
Ortega y Murillo